we've come to the Okavango Delta in
Botswana Africa to join the rare and
endangered Pangolin which looks like a
walking artichoke on its quest for a
meal there's just one problem we won't
be enjoying any foods that require teeth
because the Pangolin is that rare mammal
that doesn't have any that kind of
limits our culinary choices doesn't it
well not if you're a Pangolin if you're
a Pangolin there's nothing like a big
heaping mound of live bugs termites the
Pangolin uses its powerful claws to rip
away the rock-hard
earth to expose the elaborate corridors
and pathways of a termite colony now
here's some really good evening who
needs teeth when you've got a tongue
that's stickier than a movie theater
floor
a typical mound like this has millions
of termites right for the plucking and
the fact they're still alive
well fresh doesn't get any fresher than
bad hay with a feast like this who needs
ketchup